today i'm i'm i'm reading an author
whose name is maurizio ferraris
he wrote the book just recently several
years ago
uh by the time the title is manifesto
del nuevo
of realism realism meaning that we're
we're finding the ontology again
and and and trying to avoid mixing
or irresponsibly ontology and
epistemology that's the kind of the base
of his
of his argument where post-modernism
kind of
perpetuated that confusion between
ontology and epistemology
okay that's that's it well it's great to
meet
it's great to meet everybody um
and so i i am mostly an artist
that's mostly my job i'm a icon carver
and um but now i
through my coming to icon carving you
could say
part of it was also rediscovering an
ancient language we're discovering of
an ancient visual language uh that
bubbled up
and developed in christianity i always
say that if you know
in the time of dante
maybe a little bit before but i would
say even still in the time of dante if
you had been
in a church pretty much anywhere in the
world whether in italy or in syria
or in constantinople or in france you
would have seen essentially the same
thing there was
a patterned language which had come up
and this pattern language had become a
universal language
and so it was in part in discovering
this
pattern language also discovering the
pattern language that was in scripture
and the pattern language that was in
architecture and in
liturgy all of these things together is
what
slowly led me to another aspect of what
i'm doing which is to talk about
symbolism and to try to show
people the underlying patterns of
stories which i believe to be the
underlying patterns of reality itself
um and and i think that to the to to uh
franco's point
this right now in this moment
in the historical moment as a lot of
scientists are focusing on consciousness
and there's a lot of scientists that are
hitting a wall we could say hitting the
wall of consciousness
the problem of emergence and complexity
all of these are bringing us back to the
question of pattern
and how pattern participates in the way
the world reveals itself to you the way
the world appears
right so the world appears to us as
patterned
and this is something which it can help
us by looking at the old stories it can
help us
rediscover these these patterns again
which are
really the pattern of reality and in
dante
this is dante is one of the masterpieces
of this
showing participating helping us see
the pattern helping us see how this
pattern that he draws which is basically
a u-shaped pattern right the descent and
ascent
is not only the pattern of the cosmos in
the largest
way and i don't mean scientifically it's
really important to to
always remember that i'm not talking
about the way that science describes the
world but the way that we experience the
world
the way that we are able to perceive
meaning in the world okay and so this
pattern that he draws
of this descent and ascent um of this
hierarchy of being you would say
it appears at all the different layers
of reality so it's not just a cosmic
pattern right it's it's the pattern of
your day
it's the pattern of your story um but
it's also the pattern
of a thought or the pattern of a breath
you know
that that just breathing in and
breathing out
follows that just rhythmic that rhythmic
pattern okay
um what's fascinating about dante is
that he is able to
show us this pattern of the mountain you
would say or the descent of the ascent
the low and the high um and he does it
in a way where
he connects all the levels of reality
together while he's
giving us the pattern and it's such a
genius it's such a genius work obviously
it's not
doesn't stand alone it's it's based uh
it's connected to other works of
literature that are there before of
course
homer and virgil but also you know there
seems to be very strong similarities
between dante's comedy
and uh uh ibn ibn arabi's
el isra there's there was a
flowering of sufi mysticism
at the time just a few centuries before
and uh there there seems to be a very
very close connection
between the way that the comedy is
described
and the way that ibn arabi talks about
his own dissent and ascent he wrote a
book called el isra which means the
nocturnal voyage
and is also mapped on to muhammad's
voyage muhammad's voyage up the heavenly
spheres
the levels of hell everything is very
very similar even the beginning of the
tale where
dante encounters animals is something
that you see in in
arabi's work um and it's so funny
because
it has brought scholars to say that
dante copied
arabi and that it's a work of plagiarism
the dante's work of plagiarism
all this you know we've been we've been
seeing in the past century you know
they're just this anti-kind of
anti-christian desire to destroy
everything uh but that's the wrong way
to look at it it's really the wrong way
to look at it
because dante's work doesn't just
connect to
something like araby's descent and
ascent but it also connects to
other stories that have been told
forever
um if you've if you've never heard of
sangre of nisa's life of moses for
example
sen gregor of niece's life of moses
follows the exact same pattern as
dante's
a descent and ascent it's not as
detailed it's not
uh as explicit in terms of of levels
but you can see in in um
in san gregor nisa the idea of moses
crossing the red sea so going down
through the red sea and then ascending
up the mountain
to receive the revelation of god is of
course
the the the same pattern
there's also a book in the 7th century
just before the advent of islam
called the latter of divine descent i
don't know if you
all of you are aware of this book it's a
book written by a
a monk let me show i'll show you a
picture of it of
the icon which has become famous
um oh i forgot i need to share screen
all right all right can you see
okay right so this is
this is a 12th century version of an
icon but which was based on
the book by saint john klimacus in the
seventh
in the writer right at the beginning of
the seventh century
um and it's the latter of divine essence
his book is a mystical
treatise on the manner in which we are
to be
deified the manner in which we are to
become
to become god by participation um
and so you can see that the world is
presented as a ladder
as a as a series of steps or a series of
levels
and the monks are ascending the
ladder up above you can see the choir of
angels
and down below you can see hell
you can see that they're kind of in
flames
and usually it's harder it's harder to
see if you look at the very bottom
of you see where there's a monk falling
down and he's kind of falling into
something
he's falling into the mouth of something
it's like the mouth of a monster
and usually in other icons this will be
represented as a kind of
monstrous head
and of course the entire pattern itself
is
there in the story of christ himself the
story of christ
is a descent and an ascent the death and
resurrection of christ
in the tradition is presented exactly as
this
descent into hades uh whereas
in christ's case it's a little different
than in dante in dante he's
he's almost like a voyager who who
travels and sees whereas
in christ's case he conquers he
he goes down into hades and he conquers
um let me show you
let's pick one
okay so okay so
this is a this is an icon of the
anastasis
which is the descent into hades
and uh and it's based on the gospel of
nicodemus which is an
apocryphal gospel but this detail of the
of the of the story of christ has been
taken into tradition and so this icon is
a fully the orthodox icon it's a fully
legitimate icon
and so we see christ going down into
hell and
he breaks the doors of hell
so you can see these two things here
these are the doors of hell
and then down below is uh hades
who is being tied down sometimes there
are two characters
sometimes there's the devil and and
death and
most often it's just death so death is
bound
and christ is now getting ready to go
back
up and is ready to ascend into heaven
and to bring with him um adam and eve so
this is adam and eve
and the patriarchs are there as well the
the people who died
before christ's resurrection um
right so let me just show you this
before i get
back into dante i just want to help you
to get a
sense of how this pattern is really
a no this is not good
all right let's see what's the best one
right so can you see you can i mean can
you see the icon
here it gives you a sense so yeah yeah
okay so the world so the entire this is
this is now
the entire cosmos which is represented
again
as a hierarchy
um so you know in dante what happens is
you have you have hell then you have
purgatory
and then purgatory kind of comes up to
the garden of eden
and then from the garden of eden then
there are the heavenly spheres which go
up
to the prime mobile where you reach you
know
the infinite or you reach the
non-duality contains like that or
something like that
um and so the icon of the last judgment
has that pattern but the bottom of the
icon here
is the garden of eden so it's already
the top of the mountain you would say
okay so the garden of eden is here and
you see all the saints are gathered into
the garden of eden
the souls fall down into tartarus down
into hell and you can see this big mouth
here
the mouth that i told you about is down
here
and then the saints are organized in
choirs of saints which ascend
all the way up to the highest sphere
where you have christ and you have the
mother of god and saint john the
foreigner
um and in here see down here
next to are you seeing my cursor when i
move it okay
so this is this is adam and eve okay
and so this is happening you could say
right after the anastasis right after
the
descent into haiti so christ takes man
and woman you know takes humanity itself
takes the the the forefathers and so the
the seed of man
and pulls it up into the highest sphere
and so this is the
ultimate this is the same moment you
would say
as dante's uh apotheosis dante's
reaching you know the prime mobile and
encountering
god probably not totally though because
dante's
dante's last moment is is above the icon
it's not it's not represented because
the last
the last encounter uh both uh ibn arabi
and dante their last encounter is a is a
is a non-personal
encounter right it's a peeking into the
divine nature you could say
it's almost heretical like it's a it
comes right up to
the the non-personal transpersonal
aspect of the divine where he sees
and that's why at the end it's almost
like it's
it's these abstract you guys you haven't
read it so
yet but it's it's like these astrak
ribbons that are kind of
pulling the the the mystic the mystic
into this divine light or this over
this over light san gregory nissa
he talks about the divine darkness
that the the darkness which is so the
light which is so strong that it is
it is blinding
and so that the first so the first thing
i wanted to to to show you was mostly
the idea
that the the pattern that dante uses
so the pattern that dante uses is really
a pattern which is not
limited to dante right it's it has
a long history right right away from the
the ancient stories ancient myths and
then it has
several you could say several brothers
and sisters in storytelling
including people like saint gregory
saint ephrem the syrian also
very important in this structure from
the syrian wrote a book
called the hymns on paradise
which many scholars see as one of the
sources of the quran
and the hymns on paradise are this
beautiful it's just
such an amazing text it shows you this
mountain of paradise
and it talks about it shows us the fall
of man and the effects ontological
effects of the fall
but also the ontological effects of this
going up the mountain
and reaching into the top of the of the
mountain
so the importance in terms of dante's
pattern what's really important to
understand there are a few things that
i think are the most important one of
the most important
is uh what franco mentioned before is
that
dante wrote in la and didn't write in
latin he wrote in italian
he wrote in common italian this is
something which to a lot of people
seems mysterious but it's it's not
mysterious once you realize that the
gospels were also written
in in the vulgar greek the the gospels
were written in coiny greek which was
the common the common language of the
day
and it has to do with the desire to span
all aspects right to go all the way down
to
to be able to show that everything is
connected right if you can
express the highest aspect if you can
express
the nature of the infinite in a common
language
then you are actually connecting the
levels of the latter together
right you're you're not you're not and
it really is
it ends up being like a christian
message in the sense that
there is a sense in which all of this is
really connected and that all of this
is able to express this pattern like
this this powerful pattern
um and so then what he does in the story
is that he
then shows you that the pattern
this pattern of the mountain or the
pattern of paradise the parent
the pattern of the hierarchy is a it's a
fractal pattern
so so what do i mean by a fractal
pattern it means that
the pattern of dante's
comedy is happening in the story itself
it's also happening in his cosmic
telling of the story
that is the entire cosmos is resolving
itself into
the top of this hierarchy but then it's
also
happening at all the different levels
that dante
is talking so dante has a cosmic aspect
which is the entire creation how it
participates
in this pattern up to the angels in all
of this
then there's a specific christian
pattern
which is to connect the story of
christianity so as he ascends
he reaches different he encounters
different prophets different saints
different um different angels and
ultimately he sees the mother of god
in in one of the highest fears as this
ultimate image
you know of his beloved being
transformed into this universal
this universal thing um
but there's also other stories there's
also his own personal story is also
going through that like i said the fact
that beatrice
becomes doesn't literally become but is
replaced at some point
or is transmuted into the the mother of
god
is showing how his personal story
is being connected to the universal
story
he's showing how his personal
transformation
how his passion for this young lady
which was
strange let's be honest uh
can be transmuted into something higher
right can be transmuted into
a love of something which will bring him
bring him higher and so it happens at
his own personal level
but it also happens at different
national levels like he
has a historical aspect to his story
where he
encounters historical figures and he
places them historically
in the hierarchy so what he does is he
creates a hierarchy
of beings and in this hierarchy of
beings
he places people in the hierarchy at
different
levels but the type of people he places
are on the one hand mythical
figures biblical prophetic figures
historical figures and then also
personal figures
right so the so all of these levels are
being connected together and what he's
what's being shown is that the the
pattern of the comedy this descent and
ascent
is happening at every level of reality
right it's not just happening
at the cosmic level
all right does that does that does that
make a sense to you guys a little bit
like it can help you to understand also
why
like i've said i said before we started
it makes the the comedy on the one hand
an amazing
universal tale which is one of the most
universal tales that have ever been told
but it also makes it one of the most
personal tales that has ever been told
at the same time
and it makes it very difficult to read
the comedy because sometimes he's
referring to some obscure squabble that
he's had
with a noble and you're like you can't
understand what he's talking about
unless you have massive notes in your
text
you won't understand but the reason why
he's doing that is because he's
trying to show the connection of these
different levels
and i think that that's really it's
important because
one of the problems we've had in in
modernity
is on the one hand we fetishized the
particular
right and on the other hand we've also
fetishized the universal like
we have this idea you know you you talk
to people who are
spiritual but not religious right you
talk to people who are
who who feel almost as if being
connected to something particular is
almost like
getting dirty right they have to
transcend
all the all the particulars but what
dante shows us is no
no you have to express the universal in
a particular
there's no other way to do it he
has to express the universal pattern
that he encounters inside the christian
story
inside the roman story with that's
really important
because that's one of the things that
dante really does
he creates an amazing he creates the
most perfect
synthesis between paganism and
christianity that has ever
been accomplished and so he he needs to
tell a christian story
a roman story uh you know a
story of his city and then the story of
his own
of his own problems you could say of his
own love
of his own you know uh his own passion
for this
this this woman um but also not just
that you know the fact that virgil is
the one who appears as his guide is
related to his own personal
story as well as a poet so
so this is really to me and anyway this
has always been
dante reading dante has been one of my
most profound lessons to understand that
there is no other way to live the
universal
you have to live it through your
particular story
your particular story your nation's
particular story
your religious story your history all of
this
it's not about denying this but it's
rather about
inside that story seeing the pattern
and making it live right making it live
again making it something
that is um enchanted once more okay and
that's part of the
this idea of the re-enchanting we talk
about re-enchanting
everybody talks about re-enchanting the
world right now
but you it's not an arbitrary thing we
can do it a little bit
through fiction and and i think that
that's useful i talk about fiction
all the time in my in my uh
in my on my youtube channel but dante's
work is not a work of fiction
at least not the way that we understand
fiction today
and that's extremely important to
understand he is not like coking
making up a world which is perfect which
is very well and coherent and
beautiful like i love toki and myself
there's nothing wrong with him
but that's not what dante's doing dante
is connecting
his personal story to his religious
story
to his nation story right to rome's
story
to the cosmic story that's what he's
doing
right and so because of that it
like i said it becomes a key for us to
see
how it is possible to re-enchant
the world
one of the one of the important aspects
of dante
which i think mark him as a transitional
figure
uh elizabeth mentioned this at the
beginning she said
that francis schaefer had identified
dante as one of the key figures in the
the beginning of the breakdown or the
fragmentation in
the west and i think i think this is key
i think that he among others is a
he's a he's like a hinge right he's an
he's a hinge between the medieval
synthesis we could call it
right the great medieval synthesis and
what is coming
the renaissance the enlightenment and
modernity and the the slow
graying of the world like the
disenchanting of the world
and it has great aspects like the modern
world is great i love i love medicine
and i love
cars i have no problem with the
technology but there's a side effect
which came along
which is this kind of graying or
disenchanting of the world and so
dante stands on the on the hinge and so
as he stands on the hinge
he actually offers us i think some keys
to this re-enchanting of the world
one of the things that i that i have
been
promoting is the necessity of
re-entering the body
let's say of re-entering our experience
you know of seeing the world
through your experience
and that is really the way dante is
doing it dante
dante presents himself basically as the
as the center of the cosmos in his story
like he everything kind of
is around him you know and and there's a
there's a certain extent where that can
be egotistical and
can be nefarious but there's a certain
extent to which that's true
because you don't have any other
experience besides that experience
you only have one experience and that
experience
is the experience of you as a conscious
being
in a body looking out on the world you
you you don't have another experience
and we can let's say we can abstract
that through modern science and this
idea of objective knowledge which
there's no i don't have a problem with
that but we always have to remember that
we're always
a being experiencing the world through
consciousness like you
you can't you can't abstract yourself
from that
yeah and so may i add something
yeah go for it um i think that's one of
the main problems with with society
today where people
basically live through screens in such a
way where they live
someone else's life like they
vicariously
feel their feelings and they have all
these experiences
from their own bedroom but it's not
their own you know like they don't own
it
through uh through a particular sense or
anything it's just uh
yeah it's a fragmented sense of being
yeah the drama the drama youtuber and
the drama instagram
uh influencer that's what it's about
exactly
um like the the depth of experience is
what i'm trying to say
by going out and conquering their own
their own demons and you know finding
their own path
and so the and so the one of the
problems we've had
right now one of the problems that we've
had in terms of religious
in terms of kind of spiritual religious
ideas that we
our whole world has been made gray
through through
kind of materialist thinking like we
everything has been deconstructed right
all the causalities have been broken
down right
because you know what if you go up up
there
there's no prime mobile if you go up in
a spaceship
you're not gonna encounter the heavenly
spheres right if you go up in a
spaceship you're gonna
run out of air and you're gonna die and
if you don't have enough air
right that's what's up there in terms of
mechanical causation
okay uh and and
we need to first be aware of how that
has broken
our entire system of of meaning but with
galileo has basically basically
evacuated our entire system of meaning
once we took galileo seriously he
evacuated everything we still use
remnants of it we still say you know
he has a higher position he has a you
know uh
he's really low today we use all those
expressions but
it's we it's a it's a schizophrenic use
if we
if we fully accept
this the cycle the let's say the the
scientific
reduction then all these expressions are
are
they're they're schizophrenic right you
know
i always joke with when i talk to
priests and and priests that are really
really keen on wanting to show me the
historical
this and that and historical this or
that and i i'm like
like why do you raise the chalice up
like what are you raising it towards
are you trying to catch the wi-fi signal
like i don't know what you're doing
because
in the purely materialistic world that
doesn't mean anything it doesn't make it
it doesn't doesn't have any meaning
but what dante offers us
is rather he offers us
in his in the fact that he's a hinged
character he offers us the possibility
of kind of reentering
i think the the world of experience and
discussing
uh the world through that being
and then the meaning can appear again
right the meaning can take its shape i
want to read you two quotes that i love
from um from kanto 29
let me just
so the first thing dante does is that
he unites the cosmic vision you know
the this idea of these heavenly spheres
and the
planetary spheres and the prime mobile
you know as just a
let's say physical description of your
of the cosmos the way the ancients
described it
he unites that with a neoplatonic vision
like a
a clear neoplatonic vision he's not the
only one who does that
other people have done that as well but
he does it very beautifully
um and so he says
so this is beatrice who talks him and he
says order was concreted and constructed
in substances
and summit of the world where those were
in the pure act was produced
pure potentiality held the lowest part
midway bound potentiality with act
such bond that it shall never be unbound
so you have to think of his structure
again okay you have to think of his
structure so
you have pure act above
and you have pure potentiality below so
let's say you have pure act in the prime
mobile
you know in the heavenly nature or in
the heavenly being
then at the bottom you have pure
potentiality this chaos that's right at
the bottom
and he says in the middle so what's in
the middle of his cosmos in the middle
of his cosmos is
that place at the top of the mountain
right at the top of the mountain
is the garden garden of eden
and in that place is the place where
they join together where act and
potential join
in that spot in a place where he says
that will never be
unbound now that's it
right that's the pattern that's there in
the bible as well
right it's not it's it's the in the
bible you have heaven
you have earth and then you have the
garden of eden i always
keep having to remind people that the
garden of eden is a mountain
it's not a it's not a it's not flat the
garden of eden is a mountain and people
always forget it's a mountain because
it doesn't say that in genesis it says
it in the in ezekiel
that the garden is a mountain but
traditionally really you have to
understand the garden
as a mountain or else it doesn't make
any sense so the garden is a mountain
you have heaven and and earth you have
pure essence pure potential
and the place where it meets is the top
of the garden
where the tree is but also where man is
ultimately where the cross is right
ultimately where the crucified one is
so you have to understand that the top
of the mountain in dante's paradise is
the top of the garden
but it's also the top of the golgotha as
well
it's also the place of the crucified and
you see that
abundantly in medieval literature in
medieval representations where
the tree the the cross is represented as
the tree
of life or the tree of knowledge or both
at the same time
uh the tree of life and death you see
all these representations
in uh in um in medieval representation
and so
that's the spot right that's the but
that's also the spot
where we are called to be like that's
the spot where we are called to be
as those that unite meaning
and potential right name and
the fragmentation that's at the bottom
right and this is something that
is not when i talk about the fractal
structure of reality
this is something that is true of all
levels of reality
right that is i always use the same
examples but
any
anything any object right you know a
chair
for example is a meeting of meaning
pattern and potential
right it has a bunch of parts it has
legs and colors and
all of this right and then it has a
purpose
and so for that that comes together
in a place which is the the chair and
we play a part in that we play a part in
consciousness plays let's say
consciousness is better consciousness
plays a part in
connecting those two together that spot
where meaning and potential meet
and dante talks about that as being the
very pattern of
the cosmos like his whole pattern that's
what he's that's what it is
it's potential act you call essences
he says sub they translated as
substances but probably better to say
essence let's say
essences or i or ideas or
names and then potentiality
at the bottom chaos at the bottom and
this comes together
so you have a bunch of you have a bunch
of stuff you have
paint and you have you have pieces of
wood and you have
a piece of leather and then you gather
it together you gather all this
potential this multiplicity you gather
into us into an identity which is the
chair
and then you have a chair you need both
you need the pattern
and you need the gathered potential all
right does that make sense
yes yes yeah you get so you get a lot
more of that
if you read also some of the other
authors that i mentioned
if you if you look at saint gregor nissa
and saying that from the syrian
you really get really get that all right
so last
last quote that i really love it's good
for us today because of our
our science problem or because of our
deconstruction problem
um so beatrice explains to dante that
when he's standing at the lowest level
of heaven and he says that
because dante encounters these souls at
all the different
levels of heaven right all the heavenly
spheres and she says that the souls
showed themselves here not because
allotted
this fear has been to them but to give
sign of the celestial which is least
exalted
to speak thus is adapted to your mind
since only through the
sense it apprehendeth what then
it worthy makes of intellect on this
account the scripture condescends
unto your faculties and feet and hands
to god
attributes and means something else and
holy church
under an aspect human gabriel and
michael present you
and him who made tobias whole again so
the idea
is he says okay so dante cove and he
ascends the heavenly spheres and he
encounters these beings
and it's as if beatrice is warning him
not to have like a science fiction
interpretation
of of what he's going through right
because we have that right now all the
marvel comics
nonsense of gods as aliens living on
other planet like thor
lives on another planet and all this
kind of mormon nonsense
right and so you have that possibility a
lot of people talk about that or they
say silly things like
that spiritual beings are in other
dimensions
and they just mean by dimensions that
they're other equal dimensions that are
just invisible but that are
on the same like material exist i don't
know like
i don't totally understand it but what
dante is saying is like okay
so you have this experience of being at
different
levels of the hierarchy of beings
and you experience them at these
different spheres of heaven
and she's like they're not really
physically
these fears of heaven but they're not
there this is a condescension of heaven
towards you
for you to be able to understand things
which are beyond the physical world
right and so and he talks about like so
we represent
angels as having bodies but angels don't
have bodies
right we represent god as having hands
and feet and
walking in the garden but god doesn't
walk anywhere god is not a physical
being
right and so this is this is where i
think
that we can recapture
our experience because the experience of
hierarchy
the the idea of something which is above
you and something which is below you
is the best experience that you can have
of these transcendent truths they're not
arbitrary
there is is no better experience than
that
right light comes from above light comes
from the sun
and so of course when we talk about the
light of god we're not talking about
physical light but
it's the best image you can use is the
sun that's the best image
and it's not arbitrary if you understand
how the sun
engages the world then you can
understand
how the essences which come from the
divine
encounter light the world and make
things appear
out of darkness right bring order out of
chaos
all of this imagery you know um
so if you ascend a mountain like if you
do what dante says
and you actually physically ascend a
mountain you will have
an experience of hierarchy you'll have
an experience
a spiritual experience right might that
you might not have the insight to make
it as profound as you should
but as you if you're on the ground
on the bottom of a mountain right let's
do it even more let's put your face
on the ground right put your face right
on the ground
and look around you all you're going to
see is a is
a few blades of grass maybe a few bugs
if you're unlucky
uh and some dirt right you're going to
see very very particular everything is
going to be very
you're only going to see a very
particular thing now now get up start
going up the mountain
and the more you go up the mountain the
more you see
right all of a sudden the multiplicity
the particularity of the multiplicity is
slowly going to
start to coalesce into bigger
identities so what you at first saw
where the
the five leaves of the tree are going to
become a tree
as you ascend as you're further up and
then
the different trees are going to become
a forest
as you ascend and then as you ascend you
see more and more you
encompass more and more all the
multiplicity is under your feet
and you're able to encompass it in your
gaze and as you reach the very very
summit of the mountain that's an
experience if you
i'm sure anybody you've had that
experience reaching the summit of a
mountain is amazing because
right until the very moment that you
reach the summit of the mountain
you do not have a full vision
but at the very second i think it's a
matter of seconds
once you reach the top of the mountain
all of a sudden you have a 360 vision
you have the whole world under your feet
right and it's like
it's a jump it's a jump from partial to
a universal
scent of the world and and so that
experience
that is that's the that's the hierarchy
but that that's it
right that's how multiplicity comes
together whether it's a chair
right like when you have all the parts
of the chair
they don't they're not a chair until
you've
ascended the chair right until you've
reached the very top where
now all the pieces are together and you
understand the purpose of the chair
then the chair appears fully in its
purpose and its reality
but until you're there it's just a bunch
of parts and that's the same thing
in terms of of your experience of
ascending a mountain and so that's why i
think that dante
offers us the possibility of recapturing
the meaning
through experience of saying yes i know
that the sun that the earth turns around
the sun yes i know that's true
but your life is still based on the fact
that the sun comes up in the morning
and you just can't get away from that
like try to get away from the fact that
your life is pattern
on the rising and setting of the sun and
you're gonna go insane
right it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna
pull on your mental
uh your mental uh health quite strongly
if you try to pretend
as if that truth is not a real truth of
experience
and so if we and so that's what i mean
it's like we understand that it's a
condescension
we understand that the reality the
truths like beatrice tells dante
the spiritual truth are condescended in
the
experience of the world that this is not
really what it's talking about it's
pointing up towards transcendent truths
but
that's the way to do it there's no other
way to
experience these this is the best way to
experience these is to
encounter them in our experience
so that's what i think that's what i
think mostly dante has to offer i would
say the
the greatest thing that dante has to
offer to us is
this this capacity to join personal
with the universal to join his story
with the universal story
and to do it through different levels
right to do it through
the different levels of his you know you
could say your family your community
your your history your religion all of
these things
are the vehicle right uh
in in the in one of the cantos
it talks about how the higher beings
you know see the footprints of god below
and so that's such an awesome thing it's
like yes
the purpose is to go up but you see
that that god's footprints are below
that that that's
how god touches the the world
is through these particular forms right
the particular forms are part of the
pattern
they're not they're not uh we're not
gnostics
at least i'm not enough as a christian
i'm not a gnostic i don't believe that
that that that particularity is evil
particularly is the place where the
universal finds its
its its ground so
so if anybody has questions on my my
little understanding of dante
i will let you guys speak for now
jonathan with a a lot of things that
you're saying
especially the especially the part of
the this particularity and the universal
you know how we've lost that unity and
dante is so much
part of of unity you know he's trying to
connect it all
and in some ways he's giving us that
line
to have that experience one of the
fascinating things that i find
and it's a simple thing that dante is
never
ever letting his reader forget
that he is in the flesh and that he's
uh oh all the damned from hell
or the the purging ones in purgatory and
even in
in paradise there's always something or
some sign
to indicate that dante is completing
this journey
while he's still alive and this is very
interesting
because through my studies you know
first you
you laugh about it you say how
interesting you know he casts a shadow
he moves stones in the damned are all
indicating this and saying oh what are
you doing
here you know you're you're alive you're
supposed to be dead
but you know it it has also some comic
effects
but it it's it's very interesting that
throughout
the work he's always reminding me about
this and i've asked myself this question
why why is he doing this i know
you know you don't need to repeat but
yet he finds it
important to do this you know as if to
say that
the journey is here and now don't forget
that
and purgatory is all about that it's
possible
no matter how old you are no matter what
your experience is
that the forgiveness is there and
change is possible if you recognize
the error because one of the things
in the passage from hell to purgatory
is that dante seems it seems
necessary dante and virgil come into
contact
with the body of lucifer why isn't there
just another tunnel to go around lucifer
and you go to
purgatory no he found it necessary
to come in contact with the hairs and
the body to go
down that almost as if dante is saying
if you don't recognize the error and
look it in the face there is no change
there is no change that can start there
is no purging
if you don't recognize it once you see
it then
it's traumatic but you have to believe
that there
is that margin or the the possibility of
growth because if you don't you just
default back into the fixity which is
hell
hell is fixity and lucifer being so
fixed into that ice is the epitome of
no change there is a pride brought to an
extreme where there is no growth
sterility at its best there right
and uh i find it interesting that dante
is in his journey
he's always indicating how difficult he
is you know he'll faint
he'll have doubts he'll need to be
pushed on you know
and he's he he communicates it's not a
simple thing
you know to actually grow spiritually
and a firm life which is paradise you
know i remember
listening to a professor giving the sum
of of what the the divine comedy is for
him you know he's saying
if if hell is fixity and there's no
change purgatory has to be
the consciousness of knowing and
identifying the air and changing and
growing and education you know and then
paradise finally the affirmation of life
dante
becomes self-mastery you know he can
decide and he has power over his will
and uh yeah that kind of he summed it up
that way i thought it was interesting
the fact that
this fixity that then in purgatory
becomes this pilgrim who
uh so humbly and the humility you know
having
pride as the very first terrorists
almost at the base that all
sins kind of branch from pride and
humility
as being all the virtues are kind of
condensed in
humility dante um
really stresses the humility part where
you really have to kind of put that ego
in check
if there is going to be growth in change
i just wanted to add that that's
interesting
yeah yeah um one of the it's it's
that part where he goes down and he kind
of crawls
across lucifer's body basically or it
almost looks like he's being defecated
by lucifer like as he goes down it's
hard to yeah he goes down the body
that's really it's not you see that in
other stories
in uh for example like in jonah when
jonah goes down
in the fish and he goes down into the
into death like down into where he sees
the
sees the pillars of the earth right down
at the bottom of the world um
when he is when he comes back up it says
that he was vomited
by the fish right that there is almost
like it's almost like you have to go all
the way to the bottom and it's as if
death
like vomits him out or like he's
defecated by
lucifer like he goes all the way really
to the bottom and then it
there's this turn this flip right and
it's the flip of
it's the flip of uh of forgiveness like
you said right it's it's the
it's repentance that's really the flip
at least in jonah's story
uh it really is that's that's the flip
it's like when you
there's a place in jonah's poem which is
very powerful
where he talks about you know he's at
the bottom of the water he's in this
fish
and then he says i like i
remember right i god has room i think he
says i remember
the temple like i remember god's house
and it's that
that memory which is the flip and it's
the
it's the the flip from death to life you
know
and there's this sense in the story like
i talked about this idea of the ladder
of divine ascent and there's a sense
in that ladder if you look at the icon
that i showed you you can see the monks
going up the ladder and they fall from
any spot on the ladder right so you're
going up the ladder and it's any time
you can fall down
and it's this idea of direction
that and humility is part of it right
the idea of the willingness to change
means that anywhere along that hierarchy
you can have access to the ascent right
anywhere anywhere in your life like any
at any moment in your life if you have
humility
and you you have repentance then
it can change and that's pretty amazing
and it's actually
there's this sense that it's actually
better the direction you're facing is
better than the place you are in the
hierarchy to a certain extent
because if you're that monk up on the
ladder and you're all the way near the
top and you fall down because of pride
you know you're it's better to be that
monk at the bottom of the ladder
who's close to hell but he was looking
up you know
right and so there's this sense that
yeah so so anyway so i think that that
image of
crawling down to the bottom and this
turn because even
geographically it's really that that
moment
in because almost as if the world turns
right so what
is the bottom now turn so he goes to the
bottom and it's like the entire cosmos
turns and then
he ascends from that low spot right
geographically we can almost can't
you can't represent it if you try to
make a drawing if you are to represent
because the mountain starts at the
bottom of the pit so you have the pit
and then
you have the mountain starting at the
bottom of the pit but
but if you understand it that way you're
like yeah that's exactly it right if you
think of it rather it's going at the
bottom of the water and then
this turn and then all of a sudden
you're going back up
uh remembering you know remembering and
and uh repenting so yeah
thanks for that that that i that was a
great uh i think that that's a good
a good yeah the other the other the
other thing the other thing i would add
is one of the things uh that are often
forgotten is that
dante starts his journey with a false
start
and this in my in in my teaching i've
also brought in
pinocchio the story of pinocchio also
which starts
with a false start you have master
chiliecho who starts to make a puppet
and this piece of wood speaks
and so he gives it to gepetto so there's
a start
then a false start meaning that he won't
make
anything out of this wood he he won't
use it he'll give it to gibeto
who in some ways is a different position
you know
uh a piece of wood can't speak a piece
of wood can't but in
in in geppetto's position there is the
mystery and the mystic
still very much alive whereas mastro
chilejo is the materialist
a piece of wood can't talk there are not
possibilities
but with gepetto there's the possibili
creativity there is the creation then
there's the whole
connection and the symbolism with the
creating of adam right yeah
with dante the same kind of thing
happens where
he's starting to go up that hill he
knows where he's supposed to go but then
you have the three beasts
blocking him there's a false start there
you know he knows he's trying to get
take a shortcut to some place that for
which there are no shortcuts
and virgil somehow like in that robert
frost
home you know uh the the the the road
less
traveled is the one that brought to
virtue and that has made all the
difference it's as if
if dante you really want to learn and
grow
you have to go another way you have to
go and come in contact with
lucifer himself if
the change is going to be real and
long-lasting
and authentic so there are no shortcuts
it means
i i think you know and dante seems to
want to underline this even in the in
the second kanto of
of the inferno there is that kind of
false humility also
where i'm not anes i'm not saying paul
who am i you know he's being a coward
that's the false humility you know and
he seems to make that
that because then the humility at the
beginning of
of of purgatorio is the right kind of
humility which doesn't mean that you
shrink yourself towards life you take on
the mission you go and
with affirmative but you put your ego in
check you know you become
creative and affirmative yeah
i think you're i think you're bringing
up pinocchio is a wonderful
image because in a pinocchio you really
do have this
it's almost that if somebody wants to
understand emergence you can understand
in through this idea of pinocchio like
you really do have this problem like you
said
it's such a cra it's such an interesting
problem to say a piece of wood doesn't
speak
you know and it's like uh i don't know i
mean do you know what a chair is if you
knew what a chair is you would know that
a piece of wood is actually can't speak
like a table all the things that we give
meaning to
in a way have a voice that that of
course we participate in that voice but
material world does have end up having
meaning as it
is brought together into into into
something um but in pinocchio you really
also see this
this problem of the you know trying to
make pinocchio a good boy right try to
make him
a good boy by following these rules do
this do that but it
he has to go he has to kind of go down
and plunge into the madness and the
chaos and the
and the you know the the his even even
his own passions ends up
taking him and but it's down going down
finally and when he finally does go down
and
ascend that he becomes uh that he
becomes a real boy
yeah he he he very much like jonah in
the whale you know
he ends up in the fish and uh he uh
by the end of that story what i found
very interesting is that
the fox and the cat
will try to tempt him again after his
whole journey
but he'll brush them off with a few
proverbs
you know he's ready he's self-mastering
now you know and uh
the pinocchio dante you can really do
some work there
the parallels are there um even the
animals like you said the tempting
animals the animals that
end up being the cause of his fall you
know if you see dante
coming up to these beasts that stop him
from going further and then you have
these beasts that pull
you see that in let's say in the in this
hierarchy of beings that i talk about in
terms of santa from the syrian
you have this beautiful image for
example
saint ephrem says that there were no
animals in paradise
um we always have this image of animals
you know the garden with animals and
everything but
it's if you follow the logic he says
there were no animals in paradise
and adam went down the hill
would come to the gate of paradise and
then that's where he would name the
animals
by coming down to the limit you know
saint grigor of nisa talks about
how when moses ascended the mountain to
go up to the glory of god that animals
were not allowed to touch the mountain
right and you can see that the
israelites stay at the bottom of the
mountain and what do they do
they make a bull out of gold they make
an animal a golden animal right
so this idea of animality at the bottom
or at the uh the limit right
your animal aspects of yourself in in
scripture
they talk about the garments of skin
right god gives adam and eve these
animal garments around them kind of
fleshy aspect of us which
which has a tendency to pull us away you
know
it's not evil but it has a tendency to
pull us because it has its own
volition you know we have all these
desires that pull us in different
directions
and that you know you have to in a
certain manner deny the animal
you know in order to ascend up the
mountain
um san gregor nissa talks about removing
the
sandals where moses has to remove his
leather sandals
in order to go up to have the epiphany
at the at the uh the burning bush
you know and same thing like leaving the
beast leaving the belly of the beast in
jonah
and like in dante
uh it's not as it's not as clear but the
fact that he has these animal block his
way
and he has to go down and around them
basically to finally ascend
there's something similar going on there
as well
mac did you want to say anything about
what franco and jonathan were discussing
in terms of the dissent
and the meeting with lucifer and
because we were just talking about that
actually in our last session we were all
fascinated with kanto 33
and that descending down the hairy
shanks of lucifer
and trying to understand why it was
that actual image i think it's really
important to understand that like
meeting your own your own lucifer
is the only real way to humility because
you have to recognize that that's part
of
yourself and like climbing up it or
climbing down it
um that's the journey where you're like
accepting that that is part of yourself
and
like traveling towards the core of it
in terms of that that hellishness um
and that it's okay but now you need to
start
uh working towards that
the the journey of change right with
forgiveness and
and what franco was talking about when
you recognize your own faults
which are the work of satan in this
context right um
and ultimately try to integrate them
into
uh assets and and building towards like
a life that
you live with you know values and
and a system of belief that
respects other people and uh you don't
have to go to those lower pleasures like
we were talking about
in franco's lecture last time um
and ultimately once you realize that
like
um breakdown
leads to the awareness which leads to
the capacity to change then you're ready
like
that's that's the point where you're
ready and for me it took a lot of uh
mistakes to get to the point where i'm
like i have to own this challenge it's
it's difficult
but the only way forward is to have
proper guidance and to have proper
accountability
and to not um take shortcuts and and
you know act on those those
uh those very alluring desires
right because there's a lot of trickery
in the world
and i run into it every day
and people always try to pull you down
to that animalistic
place because that's where a lot of
people reside and i think
to ascend past that i need to
sort of have people who who've been down
that journey
tell me how to get to the point where uh
i don't need to like
mingle with those kind of people you
know and and
ultimately ascend past the point where
um
where that's fun anymore because i don't
think
the never changing life of
you know lower pleasures and and seeking
uh the ultimate fix if you will
i don't think that ever gives me a
paradise whatsoever
and the only way to go there is humility
for sure because in my experience um
i needed to lose every sense of pride
that i had every
sense of accomplishment like i had to be
nothing in order to inherit the earth
like
it's kind of like that uh the meek will
inherit the earth thing that jordan
peterson was talking about
where uh it's not really meek isn't weak
it's
it's meek is in basically stripped down
and ready to inherit the earth
like the truth of everything only comes
when you lose
the constructs that are false like
there are our own perceptions that are
false
and um i just what are the spheres of
heaven that was pretty cool
because i made a thing to perception
and like as you evolve as a person then
your perception changes
and then you can see through the spheres
of heaven is that
close at all all right
are you asking me well i've the spheres
of the heaven are the spiritual
spheres right they're the non-physical
let's say the the intelligences or
the essences as you see in the in the uh
the quote that i mentioned where it
talks about above you have
as you ascend you have more pure
spheres or pure patterns you could say
it that way something like that and as
you descend then those
patterns manifest in actual
beings um so that's the so the way
like saint maximus the confessor who is
he's definitely recommended if you're
interested in these
these ideas or these mystical ideas he
talks about
let's say like i said like the christian
vision is that
as you ascend in a platonic very similar
to a platonic sense where you
you you suddenly see the patterns or you
experience the
pure patterns of reality right then you
also notice
like i said the footprints of god below
and so
say maximus talks about how as the
mystic ascends
and the sees these patterns these pure
patterns of reality
he also notices that that phenomena is
not
actually different from it right that
it's actually those
those two are actually joined together
in phenomena when dante says that
bound in a manner in which they can
never be unbound
which is that that the unity of the
pattern and the multiplicity of
of the world are bound together in a way
that
that is not that cannot be completely
unbound
right so the pattern of something needs
its instantiation
um so sorry if that's a bit abstract but
uh
yeah the other i i i would just add to
that
that in those spheres what's interesting
is that they correspond to those seven
liberal arts
that form dante and the tone of the
language will kind of reflect those
uh liberal arts but the
the people or the the figures that he
meets very interestingly in paradise
are people who actually did something
about something
yeah they they're they're not their
purging they're
they represent like saint francis of
assisi's or the
same dominic no they they founded orders
they did something
you know dante's great grandfather who
fought in a
in a crusade you know dante is giving
you people
who actually did something about
something and we're
affirmative of it you know and many of
the examples will correspond to
something
like that right because one of the
tragedies in the
italian school system over the years and
i think it's slowly changing is that
very little space was given to paradise
or purgatory and
everything was i just read inferno
you know you know we like to joke about
it you know these people they're all
trying to justify we can relate to that
somehow
uh purgatory to some degree you know
interesting because people are actually
they're they're purging we can identify
with that you know flawed people who
have seen their
error and their purging but paradise
seems so abstract and today
the reading of many professors is no no
it's like you're you're missing the
whole point if you
completely discard paradise you know
you're condemning yourself to a life of
no change you know so
paradise actually has paradise
now is is seen in a whole different
light and i
and i in my of course in my first
readings of course i was into the
inferno the
paola francesca and all these these
characters that seem
so full but over the years in reading it
you see how
empty and and how you have to have pity
uh
for the characters in hell because
they're they're
they're in that they're living the same
day over and over and i say that
intentionally because one of the films
that i sometimes use
in my teaching is is the film groundhog
day
with bill murray if you've ever seen
this film i would really suggest
it because he is living the same day
over and over and over yeah and also he
follows a you he goes down because he
gives himself to his passions at first
and he's like oh here's a chance to do
everything i ever wanted and no
consequence yeah yeah then he kind of
goes down and then he's like okay what's
the point of this
then he purges he gets bored he tries to
become a better person
until he can capture the beloved like
it's very similar
yeah that that film is fantastic because
at some
at some point he gets so bored that he
he starts committing suicide in so many
different ways
and then he figures it out and when he
does
the next day comes so people in hell are
living the same day
over and over yeah mac i wanted to say
something just in terms of what you
talked about
you know one of the things also that
that this pattern
that dante let's say draws is also
the pattern in the of the of the church
and so this descent into hell
is also baptism it's difficult because
in the catholic tradition the let's say
that the
diving aspect of baptism has been a bit
lost
um but traditionally baptism was dying
right it's a it's a form of dying and if
you read the let's say
i'm i'm orthodox if you read the prayers
at baptism
they're amazing they're just amazing
prayers because it talks about the
monsters and the dragons at the bottom
of the water and
and and that there's all these creatures
that are waiting for you
um and so you go down into the water
right you go down into the water and
then you leave
the the super the superfluous
constructions that you talked about
like all your in theory the idea of
baptism is to
drop the garments drop the animal
garments drop the guard leave the
garments of skin in the water
and then ascend that's why the uh
the um the people who would usually that
like the tradition would be like they
would wear black garments
and then remove the garment go into the
water and when they came out they would
be given
white garments to be like these garments
of light that you received as you as you
ascend
um and the baptism was traditionally
also done
at the entrance of the narthex so the
narthex
is like this transition figure in the
church it's like limbo it's like the
limbo in dante's uh
structure and so you have this
intermediary structure
for example in orthodox churches in the
narthex
we often paint icons of greek
philosophers
uh because they're just like in dante's
limbo there are these marginal figures
these in-between figures that
aren't completely taken up into the
story but are there
they have to be there somehow because
you know
what what are you gonna do you can't
have christianity without
plato's language you can't have
christianity
without the language of the neoplaton
it's like you just can't but they're not
totally inside they're kind of like in
this buffer zone in between
and so this idea of this buffer zone and
then you're baptized and when you're
baptized and you enter into the narthex
and then the narthex is the place of
struggle it's the place where we work
out our salvation right so it's
purgatory nate narthex
the the nave is purgatory and then the
holy of holies the altar the the
sanctuary
is the place where the divine meets the
human it's the top of the
the top of the mountain right the
paradise that say the place where
earthly paradise points up
towards the the higher spheres
um so the the structure of the comedia
is also the structure of a
of a physical church like physically the
structure of a church
yeah i agree i agree fully with that uh
there there have been
studies on the number system in in
in the the divine comedy and some
scholars have found
a cross in each of the kantike across
through the number system across an
inferno
just like a medieval church formed as a
like a cathedral uh built on the shape
of a cross so
and people like charles singleton he did
much of this work and uh i if you
if you get into that you're amazed you
say how did he do it
how did he do it even you know the
italian
it will show you the the rhyme scheme
and how dante's terzarima connects
each of the verses which is lost in
translation
but it's difficult to think that someone
would actually sit down and
and work this out and yet he did you
know it's uh
amazing the things that they find in the
in the numbers you know
the seven the three the one and the
three
the twelve all very like
in the bible the old and new testament
these numbers
the trinity and the three dante has
created a work
uh so systematically organized on these
numbers
yeah it's a it's an it's a really an
amazing thing i mean i think that
i think that it becomes less
unbelievable if you believe if you think
that dante's
journey that he describes is something
that he actually experienced
like if dante experienced that which he
describes you know
then it's less surprising that he could
write something like that
you know that somehow some of it is
revealed like
i wouldn't say revealed the same way
that i would say uh bible is revealed
because then i'll get into trouble but
that it was probably something of a
mystical experience that
also informed his his writing and so
therefore the pattern would have been
so intuitively grasped by his old being
that it would flow out of him
as he was writing it you know um that's
the only way i can understand it because
like you said it's
so dense and so and so worked out that
you think oh my goodness how could
somebody sit down and mathematically
work out this whole thing it just seems
impossible yeah
so jonathan just a few comments on
what what is what's the end result
movie or what is the what is he looking
for to happen in himself
or in other people who read this or
travel on the journey
i don't know if that's a i would say
deification i don't see any other
i'm sorry it just seems like we're just
talking like in the world
i don't know i haven't i've i haven't
been deified i don't really totally know
i mean you have glimpses of it you have
glimpses of it which is
to fully realize not not just in thought
but in being
to fully realize the
integrity of everything right to fully
realize how everything is connected
through this this hierarchy and that we
participate in that connection and we
are called to be joined as much
as is possible with the source of
of all of it right i think that that's
that's the point is that
dante is ultimately joined with god
um i don't see i don't see another and
it's hard to say because like i am
enjoying with god so i'm not you know i
don't want to
i don't want it to sound like i'm being
presumptuous but it seems like that's
what he's talking about
like he's talking about illumination
he's talking about
liberation whatever religious type word
you want to use
nirvana i don't know like he's talking
about reaching
freedom from manifestation but also the
fullness of
of everything i don't see
i don't i that's what i see but it like
i said it's and it's interesting
it's interesting that that franco woody
when he talked about how we
right now we're just obsessed with uh
with hell like we're just obsessed with
inferno because
that's our world like it's not
surprising that that that's what we're
obsessed with like
that's the the things in inferno are the
things with preoccupy
preoccupy us in our society those that
so that's where we are
like we are in inferno uh and
so you know i don't know i um it's
sorry i i i i agree
the the thing about you know the the
the depth experience that dante's
talking about
and uh the the infinity you know i think
it was
a lecture i i heard of the
father robert baron he he
did a lecture on purgatory and uh
he was he he made this comment on uh i
think it was something like this that
we're
we're we're wired we're hot wired for
infinity
yep and we we look for it in finite
goods
which will never respond our desire for
infinity
and we won't get it until we find god
put
simply right and dante i think stumbled
upon this you know when he talks about
his experience with
beatrice that experience evolved into
something that doesn't happen with poets
like
guido cavalcante for example his friend
who
was uh at the korean and the atheist
no and it's very interesting dante will
dedicate
vita nova his experience with beatrice
to cavalcante
to make the point to say cavalcante this
is what you're not
seeing right because to make then be a
tricia a vehicle towards the spiritual
is the big innovation for dante that's
how we distinguish him from
the dolce steel novisti poets that i
studied
no where he brings in this other element
and the mortality the death of beatrice
does it
he ends that work saying i have to say
something else but i'm not ready
so he takes 10 years to read boethius
saint augustine
and then finally when he's he he starts
writing it and his
his exile they say really did it dante
went through some pretty tough uh
situations he was at the head of his
political
uh reality in in florence and having
lost that
some some people say that the exile was
a blessing in disguise
that all the energy needed to stimulate
him to do this
was in that experience of the exile you
know like
boethius in the consolation of
philosophy who loses
everything and from that uh you know
it comes this this this work what do you
hold on to
when you've lost it all right yeah i had
a very
similar exile actually like the same
structure
of exile wherein i had uh
a reputation i had a certain amount of
followers
if you will in this addictions
counseling
journey of mine and people look up to me
and then it was all stripped away in an
instant
and uh really knowing what was at the
core of my being
was the only thing that got me through
that like understanding that
i was worthy of
rebuilding a life that i was proud of
and taking responsibility for that
really got me through that exile so i
feel like plummeting from that high
place which was false pride
looking back it was entirely based on
false pride because i wasn't
all that in the first place um
it gave me that sense of uh of realness
and just becoming a person
who's part of something like integrity i
love the fact that you mentioned
integrity
because that word is just so powerful
like
the full realization of integrity is
like i am part of the world
and i have a responsibility to be part
of the world
responsibly like i i have a
higher calling to be someone who acts
integrally to the world and i thought
that was really interesting too
jonathan i have a question are are you
at all familiar with
um uh kabbalah the
ancient jewish mysticism and are there
any correlations
that you see with christianity i know
numerology is a really big part of that
as well
i'm just curious about thee well i think
that's true it's a little difficult
because the word kabbalah is so
is so big and so
it's a twisted word because it means all
kinds of things for all kinds of people
um i think that i think that there are
some aspects
of mystical judaism let's say it that
way there are some aspects of mystical
judaism which i think are actually
quite uh powerful and very
close to and can help us understand
uh christianity can help us understand
uh
kind of our spiritual journey and i
think there are other aspects which
are less so and so the word kabbalah is
complicated because they're
because they're different there are
different strains for example
you know if you look at lyrionic
kabbalism
there are some aspects in lurianic
kabbalism which are difficult
for us because they posit the world as
being let's say almost
as if the world is fallen in itself
right and so luria posited
and lurianic kabulism is probably the
most known form of kabbalism right now
and so
luria posited this idea of the what he
calls the broken vessels which is
the idea that the world cannot contain
god and so when god tried to
create and put himself in the world then
the vessels broke and shattered
and that's the fall the fall is a cosmic
fall before
before it is a that's a it's a fall
almost at the point of creation
you know uh so it's not totally gnostic
in the sense that it's not an evil god
that created
an evil world um but it's the idea that
right at the
instance of creation the world fragments
and
falls apart because god cannot
the world cannot contain god and so then
the rest of creation the story of
creation is
the restoration of those broken vessels
right
right right so i think that that
that kind of thing is that type of thing
is problematic
in terms of at least in terms of in
terms of understanding
at least it's not the christian
understanding of of the world like
the the christian understanding of the
world is that all is good that the world
is good that the world is not
bad it's not it's not uh and that
like like when we talk about dante it's
rather that all things can participate
in god
to the level at which they are right and
so the world is actually
full of god's glory the world is full of
his glory but the problem is only when
we tend to want things to not be in
their place
right so pride is the is the reason for
the fall
not not a cosmic accident or not a
cosmic
uh mismatch uh but it's rather pride
so it's things that don't want to be in
their place that's that's what causes
the fall so it's just i'm just giving
you a little example
just to say that kabbalah has been
has been in a way kind of deluded in
popular culture as this just basic
thing but it's not it's just it's it's a
really
complex and so if you read
so if you read let's say very very very
abstract texts uh it's it's different
from let's say more magical kabbalah
that is more practical
and more based on spell so if you read
the zohar
in the zohar you find spells on how to
do this and that
and this and that you know but if you
read the the
the so i forget the name of the
forget the name of the book which is
horrible
it's gonna come to me but if you read
the more abstract text then it's
different it's just a different thing
um so so i would say that yeah i would
say that one of the problems is that
it's just been deluded in culture to a
point where
i don't know when people use that word
what they're referring to
okay because i know that a basic tenet
if you like of judaism
is that concept of tikkun olam which is
repairing the world and if you help one
person
you're you're really connecting to make
the world a better place but that sort
of
in my mind kind of resonated in what you
said about
um action and then and what franco said
about
needing to act to actually do something
i agree no i i think that the idea of
restoring
creation i think that is true that
that's also that is our
function and so in a way maybe in the
end the acts
that we pose in terms of of restoration
and in terms of
love like in christianity we would say
love we would say that
that the world exists through love right
and love is
the manner in which multiple things
exist in unity
without dissolving their multiplicity
right so multiple people exist together
in one let's say a family that loves
each other but that unity doesn't
destroy the the different members of the
family
it doesn't suck one into doesn't suck
the multiplicity into the unity
so this balance between multiplicity and
unity
is them is the way in which god
is revealed in the world it's through
love and it's the mode of being of god
um so but so like you said so maybe in
the end
the actions that people will pose will
will resemble that
through this through this this gathering
of the vessels it's possible
it's possible but i also don't want to i
don't want to gloss over
the differences like i don't want to
gloss over the idea of
of an ontological fall right
like a fall which is at the very root of
of the
of creation which is something that we
that at least as christians we we we
don't
we don't want to include in our system
that that the reality at the outset
was fallen i don't that makes sense
what i mean the difference let's say yes
maybe it's just
the language because yeah but um judaism
doesn't believe in
the concept of original sin for example
but the tree of knowledge has great
you know symbolic meaning in terms of
awareness of the duality of life and
good and evil and
and then the concept of free will
versus the patterns of reality that you
expressed or
you know that that um
you know that's always been a
fascination for me how those two
things can coincide and how much do you
need one or the other
right yeah that makes sense that
relevance of free will
and predestination or whatever words you
want yeah the will of god let's say
and the will our individual will how
those join together in a dance of some
kind
some kind of symphony of of different
levels of being that that kind of
play together and interact together um i
think
in terms of the in terms of original sin
you might find it surprising that
the orthodox also don't believe in
original sin so
it's not all christians who believe in
the doctrine of original
sin not in the sin not in the sense of
sin being transmitted
like through the line now this idea that
we inherit the sin of adam
is something that is not it's just not
present in
in orthodox thinking we we there's an
idea of
inherited death that we inherit the the
we inherit death through adam but we
don't inherit
sinfulness so we don't have uh so the
orthodox
don't have a doctrine of immaculate
conception for example
because we don't we don't need it like
we don't need this doctrine that
that let's say mary was born without sin
because we don't believe that you're
born in sin
that you're born with sin let's say